Film Courage: Is someone writing for themselves
or for the industry?
Lee Jessup: That’s a good question.
Somebody is writing the stories that they
love, that they are passionate about.
I don’t believe in writing to the market
because ultimately you will also be behind.
What you’re writing now, if you’re with
whatever is happening in the industry, whatever
is happening in the industry right now, in
six months it is going to be dated.
So I think writing to the industry can be
a losing battle.
While you should write with an awareness of
your audience (who you audience is) whether
it’s television or film, who would watch
this show?
Where would this show belong?
What season does this film get released?
Is this a summer blockbuster?
Is this an end-of-year movie?
Is this a February movie?
Is it going to be a movie for 16-to-24-year-olds?
Or is it going to be a movie for 49-year-olds
and older?
What are we talking about?
You should be aware of all of those things
but you shouldn’t write to them.
I think the moment when you try to engineer
your work toward something, it loses its brilliance.
I know somebody (a manager) who was working
with his girlfriend to engineer a script for
the blacklist, for the list (The Blacklist).
Ultimately, that script was never finished
because it was engineered.
And the manager then came back to me and said
“Yeah, we tried to engineer it.
Clearly a bad idea.”
So you have to listen to your heart song in
that sense.
You have to really write the original, exciting
material that is uniquely yours that is the
story you will do anything to tell with some
awareness of how the market will and won’t
receive it.
If you want to write a script that is going
to be full of singing and speaking eels, it’s
likely going to be a challenge.
But if you have to do it, do it.
But write it in a way that is true for you.
Write the story that you want to tell in a
way that is exciting to you but can be digested
for the market that it’s for.
Question for the Viewers: Do you write scripts
you know you can sell?